in spiritual gifts volume 1 on page 43
Ellen White the Adventist prophetess
writes I saw that Moses passed through
death but Michael came down and gave him
life before he saw corruption Satan
claimed the body as his but Michael
resurrected Moses and took him to heaven
the devil tried to hold his body and
railed out bitterly against God
denounced him as unjust in taking from
him his prey but Michael did not rebuke
the devil although it was through his
temptation and power that God's servant
had fallen Christ meekly referred him to
his father s saying the Lord rebuke thee
so is Jesus Michael the Archangel the
Adventist Church would have us think so
which is why we are going to examine
this more closely today you're going to
want to watch this through to the end as
there will be some very important
distinctions that have to be understood
especially if you are going to use this
argument apologetically with Seventh Day
Adventist there will also be a bonus
point now I see a lot of Christians that
love to use the Michael the Archangel
argument against sdas when contending
for the true Christ but unfortunately
there is a lot of conf confusion
regarding what the SDA Church teaches on
the subject sdas are often falsely
saddled with the Jehovah's Witnesses
position which is that Jesus is an
Angelic being but this is incorrect
that's not what SD believe so what does
the SDA Church teach and is it biblical
as we read from Ellen White the SDA
Church does indeed teach that Jesus is
Michael the Archangel but they claim
that the word Archangel is a title not a
type of angelic being this is to say
they think that Michael is simply a
another name for Jesus who is not an
angel but the commander of the Heavenly
Angelic armies in fact many times you'll
see them claiming that Archangel is a
unique title reserved for Jesus there's
only one Archangel and this further
evidences that it's Jesus such as former
SDA evangelist Henry farband who states
the term Archangel is found only twice
in scripture in 1 Thessalonians 4:16 it
is the voice of the Archangel that
awakens the dead in Jude 9 the Archangel
challenges Satan about the body of Moses
both times the word is defined as the
Archangel never an archangel or one of
the archangels this clearly implies that
there's only one Archangel now we'll
come back to this claim a little bit
later but understand that the SDA church
does not teach that Jesus is an Angelic
being rather Michael and Archangel are
titles but I want us to recall what
Ellen White said in spiritual gifts no
not that she errly claim that Michael
resurrected Moses and took him to Heaven
something scripture does not state but
what she said regard regarding Michael
in contrast to the Lord she states that
Jesus didn't rebuke Satan but left that
to the Lord because she rightly
recognized that Michael doesn't do the
rebuking in Jude n but leaves that to
the Lord this distinction was a
consistent teaching of hers by the way
another example of this is found in the
devotional lift him up on page 235 like
we looked at back in part one where she
stated that the man Christ Jesus is not
the Lord God Almighty again
demonstrating that in her thinking that
was a type reserved for God the father
but this gives us a logical syllogism
that we can work with to test the SDA
Church's position if it can be
established from scripture that Jesus is
indeed the Lord the Almighty then it can
be conclusively determined that Jesus is
not Michael because Michael
distinguishes himself from the almighty
I'll even raise the stakes with the SDA
church and stick with examining judee's
own theology to test the claim prior to
verse 9 Jude exorts Christians to
contend for the faith once for all
delivered to the Saints against ungodly
people who pervert the grace of our God
into sensuality and deny our only master
and Lord Jesus Christ referring to Jesus
as Lord scripture is clear such as in
the schma of Deuteronomy 6:4 and
Ephesians 4 which clearly state that
there's only one Lord but thankfully
because I know sdas are not going to
accept the fact that Jude calls Jesus
the Lord we don't have to rely on making
these sorts of inferences because Jude
himself then goes on to tell us who this
Jesus is that he exhorts us to defend
against ungodly people specifically in
verse 5 where he tells us that Jesus was
the one who led Israel out of Egypt
which is referenced in multiple places
in the Old Testament namely Hosea 13:4
and Deuteronomy 5:15 and who was it that
Moses and Hosea tell us LED Israel out
of Egypt and gave them the law the Lord
the Almighty God which means in judee's
mind Michael and Jesus are not the same
because he tells us Michael left the
rebuking to the Lord in verse 9 but
tells us four verses prior that Jesus is
the one that led Israel out of Egypt the
Lord God Jude most assuredly knew the
Old Testament furthermore all throughout
his ministry the Lord Jesus rebukes the
Demonic by casting out demons even uh
rebuking Peter who was influenced by
Satan clearly demonstrating that he has
no issues rebuking Satan but hold on
says Mr or Mrs Adventist there's another
Central claim we must dispel and that's
the conflation of the Angel of the Lord
with Michael the Archangel as can be
seen in the now defunct book questions
on Doctrine where the SDA Church writes
that the use of the expression the Lord
rebuke thee is significant it is found
in but one other place in the Holy
scriptures Zechariah 3:2 there the
speaker is the Angel of the Lord verse
one but in verse two it is expressly the
Lord who speaks here we find the angel
of the Lord equated with Jehovah himself
and it is he who says to Satan the Lord
rebuke thee this is a unique expression
the first biblical use of it by the Lord
in dealing with Satan the same
expression is used in Jude might it not
be then that the same Divine being is
revealed here in Zechariah he was
manifested under one of his titles the
angel of the Lord in Jude another one of
his titles Michael now the angel of the
Lord is indeed the almighty God the
pre-incarnate Christ and not an Angelic
being we know this because he is
worshiped in Genesis 16:13 as well as in
judges 622 through 24 the scriptures are
clear that that is something that only
the almighty God is due we also see in
Genesis 48:15 and 16 that Jacob prays to
the angel of the Lord referring to him
as The God Who has been his Shepherd and
delivered him from all harm but did you
notice the conflation regarding the
claim made in questions on Doctrine they
appealed to Zechariah 3:2 in connection
with Jude 9 to say that the phrase the
Lord rebuke thee is only found in these
two verses but in Jude 9 Michael doesn't
do the rebuking he leaves that to the
Lord distinguishing himself from the
Lord as even the SDA Prophet is
recognized in Zechariah 3:2 the angel of
the Lord does do the rebuking so if
Michael and the angel of the Lord are
the same figure Jesus Christ then why
didn't Michael do the rebuking in Jude n
so this badly backfires on them they are
taking two distinct figures and equating
them together when they are not the
angel of the Lord is the pre-incarnate
word whereas Michael the Archangel is a
powerful Angelic creature he didn't
rebuke Satan in Jude 9 because he
recognized that the devil was a
formidable Foe and was wise enough to
leave the rebuking of him to the
almighty God but lastly remember how we
looked at one of the other common
defenses being that Archangel is a title
uniquely reserved for Jesus well in the
September 14 1882 issue of the signs of
the times an official orgon of the SDA
Church Ellen White is documented saying
that Satan was what in heaven an
archangel so no Jesus is not Michael the
Archangel but understand that the SDA
church does not teach the same thing
that Jehovah's Witnesses do they don't
claim that he is an angel however their
prophetess who holds divinely inspired
Authority distinguish Jesus from the
Lord the Almighty making him a lesser
Divine being in doing so which was the
consistent teaching of hers also don't
take the bait when they appeal to the
Protestant reformers that held to
Michael the Archangel being a type that
pointed to Jesus Jehovah's Witnesses and
sdas alike love to appeal to them to try
and support their views but all of the
reformers were Orthodox trinitarians
that believed Jesus is the Lord the
Almighty God one with the father and the
spirit something that both SDA and
Jehovah's Witnesses reject so appealing
to the Protestant reformers is
superficial if you're going to use this
apologetic with sdas stick to pointing
out that Jude clearly didn't believe
that Jesus was Michael because Jude
believed that Jesus was the Lord and yet
distinguished Michael from the Lord
don't try and argue with them that they
teach that Jesus is an angel
even if we know from scripture that
Michael is an angel SD do not think so
so utilize what they do believe and
point out the error from there however
if you do want to see actual Angelic
heresy in Adventist theology check this
out